well literally just in the past couple
of minutes i've just had this in from
pretty patel's team the home secretary
is not going to stand for the leadership
of the conservative party and to be the
next prime minister priti patal
you can see her there on your screen the
home secretary and a clear right wing
leader and potentially leading candidate
in the party has decided not to stand
she already had
12 endorsements publicly but overnight
after discussing it with colleagues she
has decided not to throw her hat in the
ring i have a statement from her uh
priti patel says i'm grateful for
encouragement and support colleagues and
party members have offered me in recent
days suggesting i enter the contest i
will not be putting my name forward
she goes on to say as home sector i've
always put the security and safety of
our country and national interests fast
and my focus is to continue working to
get more police on our streets support
our amazing security
services and keep our country safe
she then goes on to say as a lifelong
and committed conservative i will always
make the case for freedom enterprise and
opportunity and work with colleagues to
deliver these values she then goes on to
say like other conservative mps she will
be listening to cases being put forward
by all the candidates standing in the
leadership
race and trust the context will be
conducted in a good spirit that brings
our party together now pretty patel not
standing why is this a big deal well
there has been
a lot of discussion should i put it on
the right of the party in the past 48
hours about who should and shouldn't
stand swella bravaman the attorney
general and a a clear right winger and
and clear brexiteer
she put her name forward very quickly
literally on the night
just before boris johnson's resignation
she announced on
the pesten show that she wanted to stand
for leader and she had some backing of
the
erg brexit group there then was
discussion about whether pretty patel
should also go into the race so you've
got pretty patel
badenock uh kemi badenock
suella braverman and then liz trust on
the right of the party all vying really
for the same base of voters now what's
happened uh in the past few hours is
jacob rees-mogg
and
nadine doris have both publicly come out
in support for liz trust and it looks
like
the right of the party the right wing of
the party could be coalescing now
around liz truss pretty patel obviously
decided that she was just too many
people to enter the race so pretty patel
is not standing the question now is who
does she back